A prayer that's way more than just a prayer.
A mysterious dragon "too big for this world."
"House of the Dragon" is heating up — here's
what you may have missed in Episode 2.
Episode 2 begins with some gnarly
images of sea life cleaning the
flesh off the bodies of sailors
who appear to have washed ashore.
In the next scene, a furious Corlys Velaryon
bursts into a small council meeting and says
something must be done about the Stepstones,
the Free Cities, and the Crabfeeder.
"Four ships have now been lost!
The last one was flying my banner."
Otto Hightower's solution is to pay off the
families of the victims and refund Corlys
for his losses, but the Sea Snake doesn't
think this course of action goes far enough.
In the premiere, Corlys speaks of the
Triarchy and someone named Craghas Drahar.
In Episode 2, when Corlys asks Daemon
if he's heard about the "trouble in
the Stepstones" in an attempt to
recruit him into the war he wants,
Daemon replies that he has heard something about
some Myrish prince. Craghas, the Crabfeeder, and
this prince are one and the same, and the Triarchy
is the Free Cities of Lys, Myr, and Tyrosh.
The Crabfeeder came by his nickname honestly.
Feeding sailors to the crabs might seem like a
metaphor for sea warfare, but Craghas literally
feeds his victims to his namesakes by fixing
their bodies to stakes at low tide and letting
the crabs do their thing. The source material,
George R.R. Martin's "Fire & Blood," leaves
more to the imagination and simply explains
that the name was related to the inventive
punishments he inflicted upon his enemies.
History buff King Viserys is building (or at least
commissioning) an elaborate model of Valyria,
the home of the Targaryens and the other
now-extinct dragon-riding families.
"The city of 1000 years, and
all that men had learned.
The doom consumed it all alike.
And neither of them turned."
During one of their visits in Episode 2, he
explains his project to the young lady who's
obviously been sent to seduce him, Alicent
Hightower, daughter of the Hand of the King.
Viserys waxes poetic about how
Valyria was built into a volcano,
like Dragonstone, so its people could be
close to the source of their magic and power.
He tells of blood mages and a civilization
that was 1,000 dragons strong.
"Do you believe that Westeros could
be another Valryia, your grace?"
The king answers that it depends on whether
she means Valyria at its peak or at its fall,
referring to the Doom of Valyria. Though
Martin has not yet written a definitive
account of exactly what happened, Valyria
suffered some apocalyptic event about a
dozen years after the Targaryens fled, thanks
to the prophetic vision of Daenys Targaryen.
Some characters speak of the Doom as if
it was an unavoidable natural disaster,
but the strong implication is that
the Valyrians brought collapse upon
themselves with their lust for magic and power.
Viserys considers his own kingdom with 10 dragons,
already falling into disrepair after 100 years.
"The glory of Old Valyria
will never be seen again."
Maybe not the glory, but perhaps the hubris
and ruin. Viserys thinks ruling over peace
means throwing feasts and tourneys, not
making difficult but necessary decisions.
Meanwhile, the seven hells
are about to break loose.
It's incredibly symbolic when he
drops and breaks a dragon figurine
and mistakes Alicent's ambition
for kindness when she has it fixed.
"For thousands of years the Valyrians were best
in the world at almost everything. And then…”
“And then they weren’t."
Episode 2 makes it clear that
Alicent Hightower is a willing
participant and not just a pawn in
the schemes that revolve around her,
though the nervous fingernail picking
suggests she certainly has mixed feelings.
The main plotline revolves around Alicent
and her father Otto's efforts to convince
Rhaenyra that her father the king should
remarry, and to make sure he chooses the
teenage Alicent over the 12-year-old Laena
Velaryon, who's the better candidate on paper.
To soften up her bestie, Alicent has to
mediate the reconciliation between Rhaenyra
and her father, who've barely spoken since her
mother and brother's traumatic deaths. Step one:
Alicent takes her to the Sept to pray to the
Seven in an attempt to get some closure about it.
This scene is much more loaded with subtext and
foreshadowing than it might seem upon first watch.
The Hightowers are the lords of Oldtown,
where they were once the richest and most
powerful family in Westeros. The Faith
of the Seven — the predominant religion
in Westeros — also calls Oldtown home,
and the two entities are closely aligned.
The Hightowers support the Faith and
vice versa, which increases both the
noble family and the new religion's political
influence. In contrast, the Targaryens have a
tenuous relationship with the Seven. Publicly,
they've converted, but really, they keep their
ancient customs and do their best to limit
the Seven's role in the culture of Westeros.
By getting Rhaenyra to bend the knee in prayer,
Alicent is flexing her own strength and using
the religion to which she's theoretically much
more devoted than Rhaenyra for cynical purposes.
"What do I say?"
"Whatever you wish.
It's only
for you and the gods to know."
Showrunners have promised that we'll see at least
17 dragons throughout the run of "House of the
Dragon," including at least 9 in the first season.
So far, we've gotten glimpses of Rhaenyra's
elegant mount, Syrax, and Daemon's fierce red
steed, Caraxes, also known as the Blood Wyrm.
We've also heard about Balerion, the Black Dread,
whose skull now rests in the cellars of the Red
Keep, and Dreamfyre, whose egg was chosen for
Rhaenyra's brother, then stolen by Daemon.
On his walk with Laena Velaryon, the tween
Princess asks the King what it was like to ride
Balerion. Some backstory: Viserys was the last
of the Targaryen kings to ride the Black Dread,
and he never bonded with or
rode another dragon afterwards.
That means it's been quite some time
since the King was on dragonback,
which is itself a symbol of his supposed weakness.
Then, Laena inquires about Vhagar who she says was
too big for the dragonpit. Viserys retorts
that she was perhaps too big for this world.
Vhagar was a female dragon, almost as large as
Balerion, who was ridden by one of King Aegon's
sister-wives, Visenya. Long story short, Vhagar
— the biggest dragon in the world — is still out
there, and no one knows for sure where she's
nesting. This conversation isn't just scene
filler. Vhagar is basically Chekhov's dragon, sure
to show up at some critical moment in the future.
After King Viserys slices his finger on the
Iron Throne in Episode 1, we see in Episode
2 that what started out as a small cut has
rotted into a serious health situation.
Though it occurs at a different point in the
narrative, in "Fire & Blood," Viserys cuts
his digit so badly that it needs to be amputated.
The incident scars him, physically and mentally,
so much so that, in the book, King Viserys
never sits on the Iron Throne again.
In "House of the Dragon," the Maesters recommend
maggots to eat away at the gangrene. Both
versions come to the same metaphorical
conclusion: the wound will not heal.
Viserys himself utters this exact phrase
in another context, later in the episode.
"Your mother's absence is a
wound that will never heal."
He adds that in Queen Aemma's absence, the Red
Keep "will never recover," and he's right. Had she
lived, Viserys would've remained married to her
and probably wouldn't have produced another heir.
Rhaenyra's claim would be absolute, save
for Daemon's insolence at being passed over.
With Aemma out of the picture, King
Viserys has to choose between two factions:
one led by the Hightowers and one led by
the Velaryons. Since neither side will
ever accept the promotion of the other over
their own interests, civil war is inevitable.